one of the benefits of meditation having
to do with the half-life of anger that
you know we still are going to
experience difficult emotions so when
anger ambushes you for me I I deal with
a lot of anger if I can see it if I have
an intermediologist that can tell me
when the storm is brewing is about to
hit landfall then it I may either let it
pass and not be taken over by it or I
may get a few miles down the road with
it you know a couple minutes of doing
something stupid but then I catch myself
the amount of damage as Sam says that
you can do in two minutes of anger as
opposed to an hour of anger is
incalculable that is the fruit of
meditation you can't hold yourself
responsible for what you feel but you
can hold yourself responsible for how
you deal with it